Unit 1, page 12, conversation listening.
2MM
Conversation 1.
3MM
So, nice to meet you.
4FF
You too.
5MM
Where are you from?
6FF
From? I'm from here.
7FF
Well, near here.
8FF
I live just outside the city in the suburbs with my family.
9MM
The suburbs, that's nice.
10MM
And do you have a hobby?
11FF
Who has time for hobbies?
12FF
Um, I guess I like studying.
13MM
Studying?
14FF
Yeah, well, that's what I do most of the time. I want to work, get a good job later. So studying is what I'm into right now.
15MM
Well, good luck with that.
16FF
Thanks. How about you?
17MM
Me? I like to draw and design stuff.
18MM
Conversation 2.
19FF
So, do you live by yourself or with your family?
20FF
I live alone. I got an apartment in the center of the city.
21FF
Downtown?
22FF
Yeah, right. It's not so convenient, but, um, it's okay.
23FF
I miss my family sometimes.
24FF
Really?
25FF
Yeah, except for my brother and his guitar.
26FF
It's so noisy. Pardon me?
SHOULD BE SPLIT
27FF
I said I don't miss my brother.
28FF
Now I can listen to the music that I really want to.
29FF
Because you have your own place. That's right.
SHOULD BE SPLIT
30MM
Conversation 3.
31MM
So, how about you? Do you live near here too? No, I wish. My home, my family is way out in the country.
SHOULD BE SPLIT F THEN M		     /
32FF
A rural area? You couldn't get an apartment close to here?
33MM
No, I can't afford to. So I commute back and forth. It takes over two hours.
34FF
Oh my gosh, two hours?
35MM
But it's okay. I can watch movies and TV programs on my video player.
36FF
Ah, so you're into movies. Cool.
37MM
I used to play video games with my brother at home, but now I'm almost never at home.
38FF
Yeah, I see.
39MM
Conversation 4.
40FF
Hey, I saw you on the train earlier today.
41MM
Oh yeah?
42FF
So, I guess you live far from here?
43MM
No, no, no, no. Actually, I live in a neighborhood, uh, not too far. Kind of, you know, nearby.
44MM X F
Pardon me?
45MM
I said I live nearby, with my family.
46FF
So, why were you on the train earlier?
47MM
I was hanging out with my friends a little while ago.
48MM
That's pretty much what I do in my free time.
49FF
Hanging out with friends? Me too.
50MM X F
I don't like being alone.
51MM
Alone, yeah.
52FF
Exactly.